one of the things this virus has shown
us is that there are limits to our
medical and scientific knowledge the
novel coronavirus is moving faster than
the world's best scientists in Canada
and around the world they are toiling
away in labs doing the painstaking work
of creating a vaccine and working to
ramp up testing to find out who is
infected and who might be immune never
has the world been so focused on testing
and never has there been so much
attention on the people who develop
administer and analyze those tests
Canada's done done pretty well we could
have done better I would have liked to
have seen more testing early on to get a
better sense of where we were there's no
doubt that early testing and contact
tracing finding those original cases can
have a big impact on the eventual spread
because you're stopping it from
spreading early on dr. Michael garden
was one of the leading figures in the
fight against SARS in 2003 oh yeah it's
very different I mean in SARS the
technology wasn't nearly as advanced
right so we weren't testing the general
public at all for SARS we were only
testing people in hospitals who had who
had compatible symptoms and even then we
weren't doing it until the second half
because we didn't even know what SARS
was for the first half so this has been
very different there was no there was no
community testing at all for SARS when
those on the frontlines talked about the
importance of testing they're actually
talking about different tests all of
which could be key to reopening the
world the first is the antigen test
processed methodically in a lab it tells
us who is infected right now and could
pass it on to others the antigen test
involves poking a long swab deep into
the nose - just above the nasopharynx
and rotating it the goal is to collect
microscopic material it's recently been
in the lungs which is where the virus is
believed to replicate the swab goes into
a vial and is sent to a lab we know
there still aren't enough test kits or
labs to test every one that's really
gonna be one of our main strategies to
get us out of the mess we're in right
now which is if you can have easy access
to a test even if you've got mild
symptoms if you're positive then we know
to tell you to go home and isolate for
14 days
and we can also tell your contacts to be
weary for symptoms if we can do all that
then were much more like what South
Korea has done from the very beginning
which is a lot of testing and really
doing a lot of contact tracing and
they've been able to keep a lid on this
pretty much better than almost any other
country there are more rapid tests on
the way
Health Canada is analyzing a portable
rapid test made by Spartan bioscience it
uses a throat swab and in a device about
the size of a coffee cup it's said to
deliver results in minutes in the US the
FDA has approved a rapid test - made by
Abbott Laboratories it also claims to
deliver results in minutes it's being
used by the White House but there are
concerns about accuracy and scaling it
up for wider use in addition to
diagnosing patients there's another kind
of test that's being developed and
scrutinized in Canada this one is a
blood test for antibodies which reveals
whether you have the virus in the past
possibly without symptoms and are now
potentially immune Health Canada plans
to test it first in health care workers
and select populations once approved it
could allow you to safely return to work
and the more people that are in that
category the more the economic engine
can start revenue gain so I think I do
see this as sort of the light at the end
of the tunnel which has been used by
many people in terms of how to be
actually forge a path back to what life
used to be Jim would get is director of
research at Mount Sinai Hospital in
Toronto the team there is developing a
new and faster blood test to detect
antibodies and the important thing is to
try to identify as people have the virus
and recover from it a lot of people
actually don't even know or they have
very mild symptoms and so they've
they've they're actually immunized
against the virus but and it's a big but
it is not yet 100 percent certain people
with antibodies will be immune or how
long immunity would last the virus could
mutate so the optimism is an educated
guess right now
dr. Craig Jenny is an epidemiologist at
the University of Calgary
he says the antibody test could help in
the development of a vaccine but the
reality is a vaccine could still be a
year to 18 months or longer away until
then we could be confined to our bubbles
physical distancing remains the most
effective way to slow the spread it's
possible the virus could in several
months be contained enough to start
relaxing some restrictions on our lives
for now the restaurants theaters malls
and countless businesses will stay dark
as we wait for the doctors researchers
scientists and public health experts to
lead us back into the light with me now
is dr. Taz Lehman mg she's director of
medical innovation at Humber River
Hospital in Toronto dr. NIMH G thank you
so much for all you do and for joining
us you've been treating patients with
kovat 19 you're on the front lines of
this we've heard Canadian hospitals are
still coping have not been overwhelmed
what's it been like for you I think
that's fair to say we we certainly are
coping I think we've created a lot of
capacity in the system that's that's
helped us certainly in terms of dealing
with the traffic now coming into the
system and in addition I I think
certainly we can see when we're looking
at our numbers and doing our modeling
the efforts that we have in the
community are really helping and that's
in terms of folks social distancing and
not being out and about is making a big
difference and of course we say that not
to suggest that it's made a difference
it continues to make a difference and so
it's it's crucial that we continue to do
those things yes can't repeat that
message enough in Ontario right now it
looks like about half of people who have
been hospitalized end up in intensive
care can you give us a sense of how you
assess
who to move into intensive care what
their symptoms are at what point - that
you you put them on a ventilator just
for those of us who aren't in that
setting sure so when people are coming
into hospital the main symptom that
they're expressing is really shortness
of breath that's what drives people to
leave their homes for the most part and
come into the hospital looking for care
and so when we're trying to determine
what these people need in terms of
hospital care if someone requires oxygen
that's given through many different
delivery mechanisms so if you require
supplemental oxygen through tube that's
in your nose or a mask that's covering
your face you might be able to just
manage then on an inpatient bed so
beyond a ward in the hospital but if
you're requiring
higher and higher levels of oxygen so
that those delivery mechanisms are no
longer going to work for you that's when
we look at putting you on what we call a
ventilator or a breathing machine and
when that really entails is sedating
somebody completely and then putting a
tube we call an ET tube down that
person's throat into their trachea or
their breathing tube where they're
windpipe and then attaching them to a
machine that's doing that breathing for
them and allowing us to give higher
levels of oxygen to that individual
doctor named G what concerns you worries
you most about this virus you know
there's there's a whole host of things
we're looking at this is novel so we
don't have immunity in our communities
which is why so many of us are getting
sick so quickly there's still a lot that
we don't understand about why some
people get sicker than others there's
the things that we do know for example
the comorbidities that you've heard
about people with pre-existing health
conditions but there are young people
that are getting sicker than others so
so why do some people have milder
illness than others certainly there's a
lot of anxiety and worry about lack of
other treatments this being so novel and
then not having a vaccine and so the big
question is how do you safely start
decreasing some of the measures that the
tightness on the measures that we have
in the community to allow some of that
normalcy to come back as the weeks and
months progress and how are we going to
know that we're doing that safely so
we're not putting ourselves again at
risk of
second surge as we call it